Nossos melhores supercomputadores clássicos estão ficando cada vez mais poderosos,
e estamos melhorando na computação, incluindo a simulação de sistemas.
Mas simular a natureza é um problema muito difícil em geral.
Meu nome é Victoria Lipinska e hoje vamos explorar um dos algoritmos
que pode tornar possível simular a natureza em um computador quântico.
Vamos começar com um exemplo e considerar a cafeína.
É uma molécula simples.
Para representar a configuração de energia de apenas uma molécula de cafeína,
precisaríamos de aproximadamente dez elevado à potência de 48 bits.
Isso é dez com 48 zeros
e representa cerca de 10% do número de átomos na Terra.
E na verdade fica ainda pior.
Se você tem 125 orbitais e quer armazenar todas as configurações
possíveis, você precisa de mais memória
no seu computador clássico do que há átomos no universo.
É impossível representar isso com supercomputadores.
Há esperança para os computadores quânticos, no entanto,
porque eles são intrinsecamente bons em simular a natureza.
Para uma molécula de cafeína, isso significaria representar
o sistema usando 160 qubits.
Isso parece muito mais gerenciável.
Vários algoritmos quânticos foram propostos que permitem
que computadores quânticos menores simulem a natureza heuristicamente.
Surge o: variational quantum eigensolver ou VQE.
O VQE é um algoritmo que roda parcialmente em um computador quântico
e parcialmente em um computador clássico.
Ele permite encontrar valores que resolvem um dado problema de otimização.
O VQE está muito relacionado a outros métodos que envolvem
variação de parâmetros, como o quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Identificar aplicações do VQE na sua área ou pesquisa
é algo que requer certa intuição, mas existem orientações gerais.
Em geral, o VQE é aplicável a problemas que podem ser formulados
como um problema de otimização com variáveis contínuas.
Esse é o caso, por exemplo, em grande parte da química quântica.
Com muita frequência, na química, nos interessa o estado fundamental.
O estado fundamental é o estado de menor energia do sistema.
Para encontrar a energia do estado fundamental, o VQE explora
a energia para diferentes configurações do sistema
e busca a configuração de menor energia.
Em linhas gerais, o VQE recebe uma descrição do sistema quântico
e busca a menor energia.
Ele faz isso variando a configuração do sistema.
Para começar, temos que fornecer uma descrição adequada do sistema
que o computador quântico entende e um conjunto de parâmetros que o descrevem
que serão otimizados.
A parte quântica do
algoritmo prepara o sistema em um estado
descrito por um dado conjunto de parâmetros e calcula a energia.
Enquanto a parte clássica é responsável
por otimizar esses parâmetros a cada etapa.
Esse processo quântico-clássico é repetido
até chegarmos à menor energia.
Vamos agora dar um zoom no que acontece por baixo dos panos.
A configuração de energia é tipicamente descrita no Hamiltoniano
e normalmente é uma matriz muito grande.
Em álgebra, para encontrar o menor autovalor da matriz
correspondente à menor energia do sistema,
simplesmente faríamos a decomposição em valores singulares.
No entanto, as matrizes que vamos analisar são exponencialmente grandes
e é um problema exponencialmente difícil de resolver algebricamente.
Este Hamiltoniano precisa ser representado na forma
que o computador quântico consegue entender.
Ou seja, traduzido da linguagem da química para a linguagem da computação quântica.
Mas não se preocupe com os detalhes.
No fim das contas, existem formas programáveis de traduzir o Hamiltoniano geralmente
visto na química em um Hamiltoniano compreensível para um computador quântico.
Em seguida, inserimos esse
Hamiltoniano junto com o circuit, que chamamos de forma variacional.
Escolher uma forma variacional é algo que requer certa intuição.
Novamente,
ela representa nosso melhor palpite sobre qual poderia ser o estado quântico do sistema.
Esse circuit variacional é parametrizado com um conjunto de parâmetros theta,
e também inserimos uma escolha inicial desses parâmetros.
Com base nisso, a parte quântica do VQE:
prepara o estado de referência, por exemplo, o estado zero;
usa um circuit quântico parametrizado, a forma variacional, para preparar um estado quântico
para um palpite inicial de parâmetros no computador quântico; e estima
a energia correspondente ao estado avaliado pelo Hamiltoniano.
Essa estimativa de energia é então enviada
ao otimizador clássico, que encontra um novo conjunto de parâmetros.
Os parâmetros voltam novamente ao solver quântico,
e o processo inteiro é repetido.
O computador quântico encontra uma nova estimativa de energia, o
otimizador clássico encontra um novo conjunto de parâmetros e assim por diante.
Repetimos esse processo até a solução convergir.
Isso significa até que a diferença nos resultados entre as etapas seja pequena o suficiente
para as nossas necessidades.
No final, o algoritmo retorna essa energia minimizada.
Ok, isso é ótimo.
Mas você pode se perguntar como sabemos que isso realmente funciona
e que não vamos acidentalmente encontrar uma energia menor do que a que estamos buscando?
Essa é uma ótima pergunta.
Acontece que nunca conseguimos estimar uma energia menor.
Isso se deve a algo que chamamos de princípio variacional.
O princípio variacional afirma que o maior limite inferior
da energia do sistema é sempre o seu
menor valor de energia, correspondente ao estado fundamental.
Isso significa que a energia avaliada em qualquer outro estado desse sistema
será sempre maior do que a menor energia.
Portanto, com o VQE nunca podemos obter algo
menor do que a energia do estado fundamental.
No entanto, podemos de fato convergir para algo
maior do que o mínimo que estamos buscando.
Isso é frequentemente chamado de solução metaestável
e é um desafio que os pesquisadores tentam resolver diariamente.
O VQE é útil porque usa circuits mais rasos
em comparação com outros protocolos que nos permitem estimar a energia do estado fundamental.
Isso o torna adequado para hardware quântico de curto prazo.
Neste vídeo, tivemos uma visão geral do que o VQE pode fazer e como ele é construído.
Mas eu te encorajo a explorar o Qiskit nesse contexto.
Mesmo que ainda estejamos no início da nossa jornada quântica,
você talvez já ache útil para os problemas que está tentando resolver.
Meu nome é Victoria Lipinska e essa foi uma visão geral
do algoritmo variational quantum eigensolver.